now that I'm here with Lilly Singh aka
superwoman hi hi yeah but it's just the
three in the 300 make senesce Lilly is
one of those people on the internet that
I love to watch because it makes me so
angry how funny she is you baleen I've
hung out a handful of times at different
events and different things this could
be a real inappropriate meme turn your
head and cough I did a video like this
with Olly white a while ago I came up
with this idea called the new toy with
Charlie a lot like the newlywed game in
it which is essentially a game where
there's no real like consequences
because you're just trying to get to
know each other the only result is fun
hopefully I can't put like seven
different questions why don't your
favorite food my favorite social media
platforms they are youtubers my drink
are your pet peeve or your phobia and
base leak so we're gonna try and guess
all of these things about each other the
first thing we're gonna do is write down
all the correct answers for ourselves
we'll be right back as we answer these
we're supposed to tell the truth I
didn't even think that there were puppy
videos but that makes a lot of sense oh
my god have you ever seen a llama videos
the other day what just every young
people tell grace is thinking look at
this what I'm using favorite drink is
the next thing let's say favorite
alcohol it's always gonna say yeah we
didn't need to think about this one last
one is biggest secret okay now we're
into the only friend game and see what
we maybe know or don't know we know
about the other person's modern-day
friendship right here well your clues
those rows should open your mouth paper
scissors okay
rock paper black
so what does that mean but you have to
answer for me okay so I guess what you
do yeah my favorite food and alcohol
doesn't count
no french fries very very close this
could be if we were in England chips
oh my that's pretty cool okay what is my
favorite your favorite food
Oh Chipotle is that count as a food my
god you know what that's not what I have
written down but you should still get up
what I put mac and cheese my all-time
who do you make your own or dog nose
$0.99 straight from the box like half
plastic it's so good oh well your social
media platform tumblr didn't just have
this discussion before Lucifer no way oh
I'm gonna say YouTube that's a good
guess but it's actually Instagram really
yeah all those filters making me oh wow
ate it all the time flavor youtuber this
was really hard and I honestly don't
expect you to guess this at all this
answer changes constantly I'm gonna say
Miranda sings maybe oh that's a really
good guess that these are real ain't
it's just Nikki but Nikki oil is a
youtuber she's got a vlog channel it's
really really funny you also like
auditions for TV and film all the time
does she like gives you kind of an
honest perspective of like I'm going to
this audition right now it's sucked a
dick I like that yeah it's sucked a dick
I like that if your favorite youtuber
I'm gonna say Miranda sings close I do
love Miranda but it's actually it's
actually you know I don't feel like
weird because I said you you can say me
it's whatever it what happened in the
Olly video you like the first YouTube i
religiously follows yeah that is very
much well now I'm really glad I said all
that earnest at the top of this video by
the video really really alcoholic drink
let's be really Oh drink anything
I mean like [ __ ] and tonic gin and tonic
if I were mainly heart you would be
correct
okay tonic sometimes makes me allergic
I'm learning about my body which is
really fun to do as an adult woman mmm
vodka soda Oh vodka soda yeah it's like
gin and tonics like more modest cousin
don't mean to make grace on the call dog
she's oh she's not she's not not called
her tolerance is way better than mine
party ones and I remember I was like
subconscious trying with oh my god I
have to keep up with grace cuz I'm
hosting this party I could not keep up
with great I was like trying to keep up
like preemptively keep Lily hose on I
was like no I have to deal with grace oh
this is in play and so like by the end
of it grace walk out my door and I was
like nothing really worked I rushed
right into an uber like head over feet
been like oh my god it can never drink
the lily again favorite alcoholic drink
well I have no idea to be honest I'm
just going to say like margarita clothes
oh yeah Osmo oh there is and makes you
feel like you have your life together
come to the fancy glass it doesn't
matter what you're wearing the picture
looks good my pet peeve I'm missing
lying liars like close close not close
at all I would be lying if I said you
were correct lack of consideration the
people don't consider it other people as
people I always - I had one I used to
wait tables all the time and so I feel
like I saw first hand a lot of people
treating you people like [ __ ] so Mike Oh
everyone's a human being guys we're all
just what your biggest pet peeve you
look it might have something to it plans
cuz your own playing so much farting
near you
I can appreciate a good fart my Vegas
the plains is good though I didn't get
really irritated on planes in that Air
Canada but what it is is actually this
is where my workaholic side comes out
okay it's actually when people make
excuses for things matter what it is
whether it's like you did something
wrong or you do something oh but so and
it's like X Y Zed of why they didn't do
it or like they can take ownership or
when they do yes just be straight and
real I also got distracted by the
technicians it instead of Z are your
phobia Jerry okay oh yeah
seriously it is though maybe it is
height height claustrophobia hi yeah
idea of getting stuck in an elevator
it's like nightmare scenario examine
gone stuck I always assume worst-case
scenario when I get in an elevator so
like even if the door takes an extra
second I'm like I've been in here for
hours
okay your worst phobia missing spiders
it is spiders related by I hate spiders
written in brackets epic confrontation
oh yeah yeah so going where if you say
specific names of spiders I can't even
hear them I don't even want to hear them
I can't even hear them I don't even want
to hear them couldn't watch Harry Potter
oh no one knows it's scores at this
point and that's the fun thing about
this game or is fun is secret your
biggest secret is that grace Helbig is
actually Flula in disguise oh I wish
coffee makes my butt hurt we had this
discussion because Lily showed up with a
rock star and she saw that I was
drinking a monster and we realized that
like I can't drink coffee anymore mixes
but her the least big is so stupid
you're it's ridiculous I'm going to say
a little his biggest secret is that
she's not actually from Canada bloody
hell okay is this part of a backstory so
I'm vegetarian okay
innovative two years when I was on set I
knew the sandwich I was eating had eggs
but I ate it because I was too hungry
and I lied saying that it I didn't know
what had a go horrible person make sure
you go check out super one I I make sure
you go follow her on vine specifically
because she's putting up 30 days of vine
in the month of January and I don't know
I you know I say that yeah I'm so good
there but hurts don't know why hey
that's what real friendships all about